My investors are my partners,
are my mentors, are my friends.
Working with them is not only
getting money from them.
They are financing you, and they
are helping you execute your vision.
They are also helping
you in everything else.
They're helping you in hiring, they're
helping you in business partnerships.
They're helping you in
surviving this mentally
challenging process which is
entrepreneurship and building companies.
They've been there, and
if they haven't been there,
they are working with a lot of people
that are doing this right now.
And their advices are so good and
take you to a different level, that I
don't know what I would do without them.